well may is national fitness month and
sports month and the goal is to promote
healthy lifestyles among all americans
and improve our quality of life bianca
holman
is live at movement fitness this morning
with how to safely get back to a workout
routine
or maybe even start a workout routine
for some of us bianca tell us more
hey good morning sheri you know we all
want to get a fit
body yada yada right but you gotta focus
oh look he's all my photographer's
laughing i feel after my joke i hope
you're laughing at home too but anyways
but you got to start in the tummy it's
what you put in your body we're here
also still in movement fitness
at uh mucho boba and i'm joined by angel
guerra ruiz who is the owner
so tell us healthy boba that exists yes
healthy boba just how you guys heard it
um
we started as mucha boba and we are here
located movement fitness
we also do the sorry about that we do
the world's first i want to say
worlds healthy boba and why it's healthy
is because
super low sugar super low calories and
it also has protein
okay good because i know you all have so
many we can get a look at their menu
over there so many different choices you
also have these protein
cookies what there is something that you
put in your boba that makes a little bit
healthier
alternative totally and what we the way
we make our boba is we use a plant-based
sugar alternative which provides zero
calories zero sugar
still the same sweetness and no
aftertaste and also
we sort of like prep our boba pearls a
little bit different providing them a
little bit more of a health benefit
all right so i know that again those
those pearls are being made back there
but you also have this green juice
and we got to get our greens in uh go
ahead pour me a sip let's see if it's
really good and if it doesn't taste too
earthy
can healthy food be tasty we'll see
i think this green juice you're gonna
like tastes a little bit like pina
colada
all right well what's inside of it tell
us what's inside so we have
a pineapple we have coconut we have
cucumber juice and we also have micro
greens
we juice our micro greens which provide
75 percent of a nutritional daily value
giving that more of a healthier benefit
than just your regular spinach kale and
broccoli yeah
this just needs a straw and i'm gonna be
good and not try to suck this down in
the next 30 minutes but
thank you so much so again we'll be
showing you that the healthy boba that
you all make here
a little bit later in the six o'clock
hour we're going to send it back to you
guys in the studio
oh that green juice looks good bianca
it's very refreshing art to get it right
very refreshing but yeah it's good
you have to get the right formula of the
kale and the turmeric
and so to get the right ingredients just
right so that it's you know you can suck
it down with the straw as you said
but i feel like with enough lemon and
ginger it cuts it
so you know a little bit yeah just keep
adding that it's healthy it's healthy
just remember that as you're drinking it